hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his prologomina to any future
metaphysics Emmanuel Kant in the
Preamble on the peculiarities of all
metaphysical cognition in part four is
going to set out we could call it a
rudimentary history of what he takes to
be the central problem up until this
point a problem that he takes himself as
providing an adequate solution to and
the question is about the discipline or
domain or science Vision shaft of
metaphysics and he says you know there's
two questions that we can ask and one of
them is you know
if there were a metaphysics which could
maintain a place as a science really
existing could we say here is
metaphysics and it will convince you
irresistibly you can't possibly hold
back from it and irrevocably once you're
convinced you're convinced and you're
not going to change of its truth I mean
that is a high ideal for any really any
Doctrine particularly philosophical
doctrines not just in metaphysics but
moral philosophy Aesthetics pick
whatever you want right can we actually
arrive at a set of however you want to
think about bits of knowledge cognition
judgments
propositions arranged into a body of
work a real science that would be
completely saying to anybody who wasn't
just being you know perverse or stupid
or something like that and Kant says
um you know that's maybe not the
question to ask quite yet
here's another question that we can ask
how is this science of metaphysics
possible Greek in in German right or
adding to that if it is possible how
does reason attain it how does reason
actually get there and produce this
ideal of a complete science and then
Kant is going to say something really
quite
interesting here if we think about its
implications
so as opposed to
Euclid's elements of geometry for
geometry as a science there's no there's
no like standard book
for metaphysics and it's not as if
people haven't tried to produce them I
mean think about for example uh Renee
Descartes
you know metaphysical meditations or
meditations on first philosophy right or
think about John Locke and his essay
concerning the human understanding it's
a you know an attempt to supply
something new which will replace the
others even Hobbs is
leviathan presents itself as being the
only true science right so this is a
common project in modernity providing a
you know once and for all thing and
there isn't a single book that we can
say yeah everybody everybody
acknowledges that everybody agrees on
that now a little bit of a detour here
um really historically not that long
after Kant is you know writing this and
flourishing in his prime as a
philosopher
we will have non-euclidean geometry
begin to arise right so we know now you
know if you take a geometry class today
unless you're doing a kind of
old-fashiony thing you're not reading
Euclid you're reading some college
textbook and it'll talk about the
difference between euclidean and
non-euclidean geometry so you know let's
say in his time Kant was technically
right but Euclid doesn't hold that sort
of status be that as it may what's the
point for metaphysics we have like
system after system after system being
proposed and there's no one single book
and what are they supposed to be doing
uh well this is where we get to the
contrast between dogmatism and
skepticism now when Kant is using this
term dogmatism he is not using it in
exactly the same way that we tend to use
it today where we say oh you're just
being pragmatic meaning you've sort of
committed yourself to some point of view
and you're not going to budge from it
because you've got your beliefs and
perhaps you haven't actually thought
them out very well but you just took a
stand and that's it right
um skepticism similarly we often will
say oh that person is a skeptic or
they're skeptical not meaning that they
don't believe in anything
um but that you know they tend to be
distrustful of what it is that people
say and and dogmatism and skepticism in
these senses have been around since the
ancient period when we have the rise of
the Skeptics the skepticoi The Seekers
and you know they come in a couple
different schools or flavors or you know
types we've got the sort of extreme
skepticism uh while I can't be you know
confident in anything maybe nothing is
true I don't even know that right and
then we have a much more pragmatic uh
sort of probabilistic skepticism that we
see developing in Plato's Academy when
it takes a skeptical turn after some
extreme skepticism you know Cicero
himself is influenced by this and that
will often like contrast uh points of
view against each other and say ah we're
not really sure sure which of these we
should buy into and these Skeptics would
often take the the work of what they
call the dogmatists the philosophers who
are committed to dogmata plural of
dogmas and say look they they have
different points of view on the same
topics they can't all be right we don't
know who's actually right or let's you
know give this person a limited approval
as probably being more right than this
one but we can't be quite sure right so
that skepticism and dogmatism and Kant
says that
dogmatic philosophy has failed to
recognize that they're working with what
he calls synthetic eye priori judgments
so he says
um you know you can be shown many
judgments that are approdictically
certain and never questioned but these
are all analytic and rather concerned
materials and Scaffolding for
metaphysics rather than the extension of
knowledge you know that's what synthetic
judgments allow us to expand our actual
knowledge or cognition and that's what
we want to do in metaphysics so dogmatic
metaphysics does
seemingly expand knowledge but it does
so by appealing to synthetic operatory
judgments that are themselves not
grounded and he says you point to for
example the principle of sufficient
reason which you never proved as you
ought to from Pure reason a priori and
then when you try to use these you lapse
into inadmissible and uncertain
assertions
and what does this mean well we're not
getting to the irresistible and
irrevocably convincing it's convincing
to one person or a group
but not universally and so one
metaphysics contradicts another we have
multiple contenders to metaphysics out
there arguing with each other oftentimes
not even fully understanding the other's
point of view and conscious saying
that's not the way a good science
actually works this isn't science this
is just a bunch of different sects you
could say with their own points of view
arguing with each other contradicting
each other he also has another very
interesting metaphor here he talks about
metaphysics floating to the surface like
foam right now what does he mean there
so you know you've got uh maybe you're
Brewing something or you're boiling
something think about stock right and
the foam is the the kind of
stuff that that you've got on the
surface and it's not really good for
anything and as soon as you just scrape
it off it's all a bunch of bubbles right
the bubbles pop and the foam dissolves
and Khan says you know that's not really
a problem for these dogmatic
metaphysicians because they they just
wait till some more foam comes to the
surface and they scoop that off and so
we get a bunch of things none of which
we can actually Place Credence and none
of which we can actually say are science
is and that leads to skepticism
and you know this appears early on as I
mentioned in the ancient period as a
reaction to seemingly contradictory
dogmatic metaphysics metaphysics plural
right there are different claims that
are being made and the skeptic says you
can't all be right and probably none of
you are right and how the hell would we
know which of you are right anyway
now Khan says something else about
skepticism I mean if it was just that
then
it would be not a bad position to take
but in skepticism reason
the highest faculty within us at least
as far as this goes he says treats
itself with violence
um it it actually does violence to its
own self it comports itself in that way
so it's this is not actually good for
reason to be engaging in right
um and he tells us that skepticism
doesn't promise us anything not even to
rest in permitted Ignorance disquieted
by the importance of knowledge so much
needed right and why does it do this
violence to itself he says the complete
despair of ever satisfying our most
important aspirations you know the
augmented augmented dogmatic philosophy
and metaphysics arises because as we as
human beings really do have a deep
yearning to understand
these matters so it's arising out of
Despair it's interesting because the
word that's translated as despair
could mean that but it's actually closer
to
a kind of deepened doubt right Ferd's
wife
is to doubt Ferd's wife is turning it
with the oing into sort of a substantive
an activity an affair intensifying it uh
you know transforming it in a way and so
this is a deepened it can be despair
because you have doubts and you don't
think you'll ever be able to resolve
them and that's why reason can turn
against itself in that way
is there a way out of this dilemma of
dogmatism and skepticism Khan says yes
and what you have to do in order to
um get there is ask this critical
question that is not being framed by a
lot of metaphysicians is metaphysics at
all possible right and this is going to
the how is the science possible how does
reason attain it this is what he's going
to be talking about in uh next section
of this Preamble and then in the rest of
the work and he says that we cannot go
the route of dogmatism just making
something up that
sounds good because it's not going to be
convincing we need to have something
that will be convincing and convincing
in a lasting way for all rational people
and we can't go the skeptical route
that's not going to be helpful for us we
can have a skeptical attitude and be
like well you need to prove things right
but this sort of Hardcore commitment to
skepticism and using reason against
itself in this case is not going to work
so what do we have to do instead we have
to use reason in a different way in a
critical way with the what he's going to
call the transcendental philosophy that
we find in the critique of pure reason
and he says in the critique I have
treated this question
synthetically by making inquiries into
pure reason itself and endeavoring in
this source to determine the elements as
well as the laws of its pure use
according to principles the task is
difficult and requires a Resolute leader
reader to penetrate by degrees into a
system based on no data except reason
it's also reason is examining reason and
scrutinizing it and so it seeks to
unfold Knowledge from its original germs
so Kant is saying listen there is no
like easy answer to this you got to
check out my big old book The critique
of pure reason or you can have the same
some of the same stuff presented to you
in an analytic fashion in the
prologomina because I've now done that
but these are just sort of preliminary
exercises they're not the totality of
the critique and so they're not the
entirety of the way forward or the
resolution of this fundamental problem
this question how is metaphysics at all
possible